okay wait I just learned something
that's kind of blowing my mind the
reason why there are so many Thai
restaurants in the United States is
because the government of Thailand
wanted there to be in 2002 the
government of Thailand launched this
program to train Thai chefs and then to
invest in them opening restaurants in
other countries and it was at this time
in 2002 that they chose pad tii to be
their national dish and it totally
worked now there are thousands and
thousands more Thai restaurants here in
our country and around the world because
of this effort some people call it
gastro diplomacy using food as a way to
spread the goodness of your culture and
your country to the rest of the world
and I think it's freaking awesome thank
you Thailand if you want to better
understand global politics and stuff
like this follow alone for more